يهربون من مدينة غزة، مع ما يمكنهم حمله فقط،
ويلوحون بالأعلام البيضاء المصنوعة من
أي شيء يمكنهم
العثور عليه، وبينما تتردد أصوات الحرب
من حولهم، يشيرون مرة أخرى إلى
أنهم
أبرياء، وقد ظل الجيش الإسرائيلي
ينادي منذ أسابيع على جميع الأحياء  في
الجزء الشمالي من القطاع للتحرك
جنوبًا، تم مؤخرًا فتح ما
يسمى بممرات آمنة لنوافذ
زمنية محدودة مما دفع الآلاف هنا
إلى شارع صلاح الدين حيث يصف الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم
رحلة مروعة، والطريقة
الوحيدة للوصول إلى الطريق هي سيرًا على
الأقدام أو بواسطة عربة لهؤلاء.  من يستطيع العثور على
غرفة [موسيقى] القوات الإسرائيلية الآن في قلب
مدينة غزة، حيث
أعلن وزير الدفاع الإسرائيلي على ما يبدو أن
المدينة بأكملها، وهي أكبر
مركز سكاني في القطاع،
هدف مشروع. غزة هي أكبر
معقل إرهابي بنته البشرية على
الإطلاق  المدينة هي قاعدة إرهابية كبيرة
تحت الأرض، ولديها كيلومترات من
الأنفاق المتصلة بالمستشفيات
والمدارس، وتصف الأمم المتحدة هذا النزوح
بالتهجير القسري وتتهم إسرائيل
بالعقاب الجماعي لحوالي مليوني
شخص، وهذه الطرق يمكن أن تكون
خطيرة ومميتة، كان هذا شارع صلاح الدين
فقط  قبل بضعة أسابيع، قامت شبكة CNN
بتحديد الموقع الجغرافي والتحقق من صحة
مقاطع الفيديو هذه التي تظهر آثار
الانفجارات التي أدت إلى مقتل الأشخاص الذين تم إجلاؤهم، ويمكنك
رؤية الأمتعة بين
الجثث ويخشى الكثيرون أنه لن يُسمح لهم أبدًا
بالعودة إلى ديارهم، ويقول البعض هنا إن
هذا يذكرنا بالنكبة، وهو
المصطلح العربي للنكبة.  طرد
الفلسطينيين من مدنهم أثناء
تأسيس
إسرائيل [موسيقى] ولمن يفعل ذلك
القصف والحصار ينتظرهم في
الجنوب
أيضاً لا مفر حقيقي